so Grace you know and I'm asking both to
protect all of us but also I have a
strange fascination of of exotic scams
what are the types of scams that you've
seen how how elaborate have these things
become
yeah so unfortunately the attackers are
getting more creative now the good news
is that most major you know email
platforms for example are automatically
blocking all kinds of spam that or scams
and spam that you never see on a regular
basis for example during the coveted
pandemic Google blocked 18 million covid
impersonation emails per day and that is
something that never made it to people's
inboxes
impersonation email
so unfortunately one thing to look out
for with these scams is folks
impersonating what you might think of as
a trusted source so maybe a hospital or
Health Organization reaching out with
covid information kind of trying to beat
people in with something timely so we do
really recommend that folks go directly
to the trusted website of that
organization as opposed to clicking into
a link that may look a little bit
suspicious or may not be something they
were expected to hear another flag is if
a email or a call or a text is really
trying to rush you into providing
personal information such as your bank
account information your password or
otherwise
um so we we were seeing trends of
attempts to kind of reach out and say
help now or please send money here we're
also seeing impersonation attempts
around special offers so you know if it
looks too good to be true it probably is
if you're being offered free items that
are high monetary value but you're being
asked to immediately you know put your
credit card information down and that's
definitely another red flag to look out
for
wow it it is a dangerous world but I'm
glad there are folks like you who are
helping keep track and feels like it's a
never-ending arms race so we have to
stay vigilant
definitely I think that's our biggest
tip is to be proactive and definitely
take a beat before clicking on something
suspicious
um and and verify you know if there's a
you receive something you think it looks
like it's from someone you know or
something you're familiar with go ahead
and find another way to confirm that
that's actually the case
and always check the link you're about
to click on and before you type in a
password think three times
are my takeaways
a two-step verification absolutely
thanks so much grace that was really
useful
thank you Sal